is General Ortega related to Gina  Rodriguez unfortunately no people might  be asking if I'm related to Gina because  I play the younger version of her and  Jane the Virgin it was one of the first  jobs that I ever did and I also think  people always love when people see each  other in projects that are related and  they're actually related it's like a  nice fun fact I'm giving no one that  satisfaction with this answer is General  Ortega playing Wednesday Adams I  actually am I've never played someone  that has been portrayed before and  especially so flawlessly it's weird to  do something that people have already  created expectations and ideas of and  still tried to do something different  that doesn't stray too far from the  character but also puts her in a  different world and atmosphere there's a  lot of pressure I think